klaus c'est l'entreprise historique de
morteau en agroalimentaire elle est né
au locle de l'autre côté de la frontière
mais si l'entreprise suisse a fermé ses
portes celle ci perdure c'est touristes
apprécient chocolat et caramel plus de
100 références au total fait une falaise
on l'a on a un côté de jambon maintenant
goûte le chocolat on a fait voilà où on
va aller faire un petit crochet pour
trouver du fromage et ce sera parfait
c'est vraiment l'objectif des vacances
et découvrir des beaux lieux et des
veaux endroit avec wade des spécialités
locales pour cause d'arrêt annuel de la
production ces touristes n'ont pas pu
assister à la fabrication
ici en période estivale les ventes
augmentent on a derrière l usine qui est
visité par beaucoup de touristes et qui
forcément génère un peu plus de chiffre
d'affaires que globalement dans l'année
il ya un potentiel de développement avec
des produits qu'on veut absolument
développer au niveau régional avec une
réelle entités régionales à quelques
centaines de mètres le magasin riem ici
aussi les ventes sont en hausse en cette
période
déjà parce que l'été on consomme
davantage de sirop et de limonaderies
n'en sais rien mais née il ya presque
cent ans à morteau mais faute de place
pour s'agrandir la fabrication s'est
déplacé à besançon les touristes
plébiscitent les produits régionaux
ça va être le côté local
le produit proche du lieu de leurs
vacances la fabrication artisanale
authentique elle est la boisson
rafraîchissante de l'été la clientèle
que je sois le tourisme ou la clientèle
locale est de plus en plus adeptes aux
circuits courts circuits proches
les commerçants ont bien compris cette
demande des consommateurs
aujourd'hui ils ont besoin d'être
rassurés sur la provenance du produit
pour eux la proximité est avant tout un
gage de qualité de réassurance le fait
qu'ils connaissent les entreprises leur
image de marque et super rassurant pour
eux voilà tout ce qui engage ou de l'onu
les consommateurs à se tourner de plus
en plus vers les produits locaux rien
mais klaus ont lancé leurs gammes bio
eh oui cerise sur le gâteau le produit
dont les ventes explosent c'est le local
bio